c'était un ancien élève de cette
professeur d'espagnol qui a été
assassiné ce matin
et quand tu as appris la nouvelle ça a
été un choc parce que nous à
Saint-Jean-de-Luz à Saint-Thomas on
n'avait jamais eu de choses comme ça qui
s'était passé et donc moi je l'ai appris
par l'intermédiaire de mon frère qui
était en cours et il m'a envoyé un
message pour me dire ce qui se passait à
peu près et donc moi je suis venu tout
de suite en bas de saint Thomas au
parking et c'est là qu'on a vu les
militaires la police on a vu tous les
enfin j'ai vu tous les parents d'élèves
aussi qui étaient rassemblés quand les
élèves sont sortis il y en avait plein
d'élèves en pleurs d'autres qui
tremblaient et ça a dû être vraiment
terrible pour ceux qui étaient en classe
avec elle toi tu as eu cette professeur
quand tu étais en troisième en quatrième
d'accord et c'était une prof passionnée
elle aimait son boulot elle voulait tout
faire pour qu'on réussisse elle n'était
pas très sévère elle était pas très
autoritaire avec nous elle était
vraiment
une prof idéale j'ai que des très bons
souvenirs avec elle et voilà on
n'oubliera jamais